♪ ♪
>> Sean: AND WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
WE START WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
BREAKING TONIGHT, WE HAVE ALL
THREE MAJOR BROADCAST NETWORKS,
FAKE NEWS CNN, MSDNC COME ALL
HAPPILY BROADCASTING, WELL, THE
DULLEST, MOST BORING, NOTHING
NEW, MULTIHOUR DEMOCRATIC
FUND-RAISER, MASQUERADING AS A
JANUARY 6TH HEARING, AND BY THE
SOUNDS OF IT, THEY ARE GOING TO
DO HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF THIS,
PRODUCED BY A FORMER ABC
EXECUTIVE, 100% HOLLYWOOD
PRODUCTION WITH ALL THE CREATIVE
LICENSE THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH
THAT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, TONIGHT'S
SO-CALLED HEARING IS NOT IN GOOD
FAITH, IT IS NOT AN HONEST PROBE
INTO THE SECURITY BREAKDOWN ON
THAT FATEFUL DAY, AND WE WILL
PROVE THAT TO YOU TONIGHT.
INSTEAD, IT IS A MADE-FOR-TV
SMEAR CAMPAIGN AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, FEATURING
SLICED AND DICED VIDEO THAT FITS
THEIR PREDETERMINED POLITICAL
NARRATIVE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, ACCOMPANIED BY THE
BIGGEST TRUMP HATERS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON ON THIS
COMMITTEE IS ON RECORD HATING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND THEY ALL
VOTED TO IMPEACH HIM.
NOW, PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE ON THIS
ILLEGITIMATE, HYPERPARTISAN
COMMITTEE, AND SADLY, THOSE
RUNNING THE CIRCUS ARE NOT
INTERESTED IN WHAT WENT WRONG.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
THEY ARE PURPOSELY OMITTING WHAT
IS CRITICAL INFORMATION.
WE WILL TELL YOU ABOUT TONIGHT,
AND WE WILL SHOW YOU TONIGHT,
THAT WILL REVEAL WHERE MASSIVE
SECURITY FAILURES DID OCCUR, AND
BEYOND THAT, SHOW YOU THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF
THOSE SECURITY FAILURES, AND HOW
THE COMMITTEE IS PROTECTING ALL
OF THEM FROM BEING EXPOSED.
TONIGHT, WE WILL NAME NAMES.
WE WILL ALSO SHOW YOU HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OUR DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT, THE CAPITOL POLICE,
OFFERED EVERY MORNING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT THE
CAPITAL, AND THEY WERE REJECTED
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
NOW WE MUST LEARN THE TRUTH, SO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS CAN NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN.
I SPOKE OUT ABOUT IT IN REAL
TIME ON MY RADIO SHOW, AND ON
JANUARY 6TH ON THIS PROGRAM THAT
NIGHT.
NOW SADLY, THIS COMMITTEE
PREFERS POLITICS OVER SAFETY.
ON THIS PROGRAM, WE BELIEVE THAT
IMPROVING SECURITY AT THE
CAPITAL, PROTECTING ALL ELECTED
OFFICIALS, IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE, RATHER THAN A
VENGEFUL SMEAR CAMPAIGN LIKE WE
SEE UNFOLDING.
SO UNLIKE THIS COMMITTEE AND
THEIR CHEERLEADERS IN THE MEDIA
MOB, WE WILL ACTUALLY BE TELLING
YOU THE TRUTH.
NOW, TONIGHT, THANKS TO THE VERY
DILIGENT REPORTING FROM JOHN
SOLOMON, WE NOW HAVE A TROVES
NEWLY UNEARTHED DOCUMENTS AND
OUR OWN SOURCES, AND WE HAVE NOW
BEEN ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
CRITICAL TIMELINE THAT I PROMISE
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO SEE
ANYWHERE ELSE.
NOW THIS IS THE OFFICIAL
TIMELINE OF THE CAPITOL POLICE,
AS OBTAINED BY INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER JOHN SOLOMON.
HE WILL JOIN US IN A LITTLE BIT.
AND WE BEGAN ON JANUARY 2ND,
2021.
WE NOW KNOW TODAY, DEFINITIVELY,
THAT ON JANUARY 2ND, 4 DAYS
BEFORE THE 6, THAT TRUMP IS
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND ONE OF
HIS OFFICIALS FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, IN FACT, REACH
OUT TO THE CAPITOL POLICE
DEPARTMENT, ASKING THE
DEPUTY CHIEF THAT THEY ARE
PLANNING ON CALLING UP THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO HELP PROTECT
THE CAPITAL AHEAD OF THE MASSIVE
RALLY THAT WAS PLANNED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
THE NEXT DAY, ON JANUARY 3RD,
AFTER CONSULTING WITH THE
CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF, DEPUTY
CHIEF SEAN GALLAGHER TOLD THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE THAT A
REQUEST FOR NATIONAL GUARD WAS
NOT FORTHCOMING.
HOWEVER, SHORTLY THEREAFTER,
THEY GOT NEW AND DARKER SECURITY
ASSESSMENTS THAT WERE ISSUED TO
THE HOUSE AND SENATE SERGEANTS
AT ARMS, AND THEY DISCOVERED
THAT, IN FACT, RADICAL GROUPS
WERE PLANNING VIOLENCE.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE
ASSESSMENT, IT SAID, QUOTE, "DUE
TO THE TENSE POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT FOLLOWING THE 2020
ELECTION, THE THREAT OF
DISRUPTIVE ACTIONS OR VIOLENCE
CANNOT BE RULED OUT," THEN IT
CONTINUED, "THE SENSE OF
DESPERATION AND DISAPPOINTMENT
MAY LEAD TO MORE OF AN INCENTIVE
TO BECOME VIOLENT."
NOW, ONE DAY LATER, ON
JANUARY 4TH, THE CAPITOL POLICE
CHIEF STEVE SON, HE RIGHTLY,
BASED ON A NEW INTELLIGENCE,
CHANGED HIS MIND, AND BEGAN THE
PROCESS OF SEEKING PERMISSION
FROM THE OFFICE OF NANCY PELOSI
AND CHUCK SCHUMER, TWO IN FACT
DEPLOY THE NATIONAL GUARD, USING
THAT INTELLIGENCE.
NOW THE HOUSE AND SENATE
SERGEANT-AT-ARMS, THEY DENIED
THIS REQUEST.
WHY WEREN'T THEY CALLED BEFORE
THE CEILING?
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND TOP DoD
OFFICIALS, THEY FORGED AHEAD
WITH PLANS TO MAKE A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS
AVAILABLE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, THIS IS
COMING OFF THE SUMMER OF 574
OFFICIAL RIOTS IN THIS COUNTRY,
WHERE DOZENS OF AMERICANS WERE
KILLED, WHERE THOUSANDS OF
POLICE WERE INJURED, WHERE THERE
WAS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PROPERTY DAMAGE, SO THEY RIGHTLY
WANTED TO PREPARE.
THEN COME ON JANUARY 4TH, A
MEETING TOOK PLACE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
IT FEATURED PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS,
ACTING DEFENSE SECRETARY CHRIS
MILLER, THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE TO CHIEF OF STAFF KASH
PATEL, WHO WILL ALSO JOIN US
TONIGHT, AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF,
MARK MILLEY, PRESIDENT TRUMP, IN
THAT MEETING, REQUESTED THAT UP
TO 20,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS
BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR SECURITY
AT THE CAPITOL FOR JANUARY 6TH
AS THE LAW REQUIRES HIM TO
AUTHORIZE.
NOW, "THE WASHINGTON POST," THEY
LIED AND CLAIMED WE MUST HAVE
MADE THIS UP.
THEY GAVE OUT FOUR PINOCCHIO'S
COMMAND AS PER USUAL,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS EITHER
DISHONEST OR LAZY OR BOTH.
THEY DID NOT TALK TO THE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY IN THE MEETING.
WE DID ON THIS PROGRAM.
FOUR OUT OF THE FIVE PRESENT IN
THE OVAL OFFICE HAVE ON THIS
PROGRAM CORROBORATED OUR
REPORTING.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> DID YOU AUTHORIZE CALLING UP
THE GUARD, AND THEN IT BECAME --
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND WENT TO
NANCY PELOSI AND TO THE MAYOR OF
D.C., MURIEL BOWSER -- DID YOU,
AS REQUIRED BY LAW, AUTHORIZE
THAT?
>> 100%.
AND ATTESTED TO BY MANY PEOPLE,
AND THEY TURNED IT DOWN.
NANCY PELOSI TURNED IT DOWN.
>> MAYOR BOWSER'S WRITTEN
REFUSAL, THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE LEADER OF THE
CAPITOL POLICE AND THEIR CHAIN
OF COMMAND TO THE DoD,
REFUSING OUR REQUEST TO ALLOW
NATIONAL GUARD'S MEN AND WOMEN
TO STAGE ON JANUARY 4TH AND 5TH,
BEFORE JANUARY 6TH.
>> DID YOU CALL FOR THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO BE CALLED UP?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT, SEAN, WE
HAVE MADE THAT VERY CLEAR, NOT
JUST ONCE BUT ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THERE WAS
PLENTY OF NATIONAL GUARD ON THE
READY IN CASE THERE WAS SOME
KIND OF VIOLENCE.
>> I HAD A MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE
3RD OF JANUARY CONCERNING SOME
INTERNATIONAL THREATS, AND AT
THE VERY END, HE ASKED IF THERE
WERE ANY REQUESTS FOR
NATIONAL GUARD SUPPORT.
>> WHAT WAS THE PRESIDENT'S
RESPONSE TO YOU WITH REGARD TO
THE REQUEST MADE BY
MAYOR BOWSER?
>> FILL IT AND DO WHATEVER WAS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE
DEMONSTRATORS.
>> Sean: NOW, IN ADDITION TO
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD, THERE WAS
ONE OTHER PERSON IN THE ROOM,
AND THAT IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS, GENERAL MILLEY.
NOW, THIS WEEK, PEOPLE CLOSE TO
HIM HAVE CONFIRMED DIRECTLY TO
ME THAT THE GENERAL ABSOLUTELY
RECALLS CONVERSATIONS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT SECURITY
PRIOR TO JANUARY 6TH.
NOW, WE ARE MORE THAN AN HOUR
INTO THE CAPITOL SHOW TONIGHT,
THIS SO-CALLED HEARING,
APPARENTLY THERE'S GOING TO BE
PLANNED HEARINGS IN PERPETUITY
BY THE SOUNDS OF IT, AND THIS
CRITICAL INFORMATION, THIS
CRITICAL MEETING, HAS NOT BEEN
MENTIONED ONE TIME.
NOT ONE TIME.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT, SADLY,
THEIR PREDETERMINED POLITICAL
OUTCOME, WHICH WE ALL KNOW IS TO
SMEAR ONCE AGAIN DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS KIND OF HARD TO SAY TO
SOMEBODY THAT SOMEBODY WANTED A
RIOT AND INSTIGATED A RIOT WHEN
THAT SAME PERSON AUTHORIZED UP
TO 20,000 TROOPS TO PROTECT THAT
VERY CAPITOL WHERE THE SO-CALLED
RIOT IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE.
KEEP IN MIND, ACCORDING TO
DEFENSE EXPERTS, THE CAPITOL
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN BREACHED
WITH THOUSANDS OF NATIONAL GUARD
SOLDIERS PROVIDING THE SECURITY.
LET ME SAY IT ANOTHER WAY.
HAD THEY ACTUALLY LISTENED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HAD THEY
LISTENED TO THE EXPERTS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE,
JANUARY 6TH NEVER WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED.
THEY DIDN'T LISTEN.
THEY WERE DEAF, THEY CARED NOT
TO PROTECT THE CAPITOL.
THEY KNEW, THEY HAD 574 RIOTS
THE SUMMER BEFORE, THEY KNEW
TENSIONS IN THE COUNTRY WERE
HIGH, AND THEY DIDN'T DO THEIR
DUTY, THEY WERE BEGGED
REPEATEDLY TO TAKE THE GUARD,
AND THEY WOULDN'T DO IT.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT CAN MAKE
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS AVAILABLE,
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE, WELL,
THEN IT BECOMES THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF
SPEAKER PELOSI.
SHE IS IN CHARGE OF SECURITY AT
THE CAPITOL, AND ALSO, D.C.
MAYOR BOWSER, SHE HAS THE
JURISDICTION.
THEY BOTH HAVE THE AUTHORITY AT
THAT POINT, ONCE THE PRESIDENT
AUTHORIZES THE TROOPS TO BE
CALLED UP, THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT HAVE TO DEPLOY THE TROOPS
TO THE CAPITOL AND SURROUNDING
AREAS.
SO THE QUESTION THEY ARE NOT
ASKING THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ASKING, WHY DIDN'T PELOSI, WHY
DIDN'T I WAS, WHY DIDN'T YOU
BURN DIDN'T THE SERGEANT AT ARMS
CALL UP LEAH TARGETED ARMS?
WHY DIDN'T SCHUMER SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, WE SHOULD LISTEN -- WHY
DIDN'T THE SERGEANT-AT-ARMS IN
THE HOUSE AND SENATE LISTEN TO
THE CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF WHEN HE
WAS BEGGING THEM?
WHY DID THEY DENY THE
CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF, THE TROOPS
HE SAID HE NEEDED?
IF THIS CITY CARED AT ALL ABOUT
THE TRUTH, IF THEY CARED AT ALL
ABOUT PREVENTING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, WHICH WE SHOULD ALL AGREE
ON, FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN,
THEY WOULD BE DEMANDING ANSWERS
FROM PELOSI AND SCHUMER AND
BOWSER, AND BOTH THE SERGEANT OF
ARMS IN THE HOUSE AND IN THE
SENATE, AND THE CAPITOL POLICE
CHIEF, AND THE DEPUTY POLICE
CHIEF, AND EVERYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SECURING THE CAPITOL.
WHY DIDN'T THIS COMMITTEE
SUBPOENA ALL OF THESE PEOPLE,
DEMAND ALL OF THEIR TEXT
MESSAGES, ALL OF THEIR EMAILS,
AND DEPOSE ALL OF THEM?
NOW, EVEN THE VENGEFUL AND VERY
TRUMP-OBSESSED LIZ CHENEY, SHE
ACTUALLY ADMITTED TONIGHT -- I
COULDN'T BELIEVE MY EARS -- THAT
THE VIOLENCE ON JANUARY 6TH WAS
NOT SPONTANEOUS.
SHE SAID IT.
IT WAS NOT THE RESULT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH.
INSTEAD, SHE POINTS OUT, IT WAS
PREPLANNED.
NOW AS YOU WATCH THIS, ASK
YOURSELF, WELL, IF YOU KNEW
AHEAD OF TIME THAT PEOPLE ARE
PLANNING VIOLENCE, WHY DIDN'T
EVERYBODY THAT KNEW THIS, WHY
DIDN'T THEY -- IF THEY KNEW
ABOUT THIS, WHY DIDN'T YOU CALL
IN THE GUARD?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE ATTACK ON OUR CAPITOL WAS
NOT A SPONTANEOUS RIOT.
INTELLIGENCE AVAILABLE BEFORE
JANUARY 6TH IDENTIFIED PLANS TO
"INVADE" THE CAPITOL, OCCUPY THE
CAPITOL, AND TAKE OTHER STEPS TO
HALT CONGRESSES COUNT OF
ELECTORAL VOTES THAT DAY."
>> Sean: OKAY, SO THEY ALL
KNEW THE VIOLENCE WAS
PREPLANNED.
NOW, THAT BRINGS US TO
JANUARY 5TH, 2021.
THAT EVENING, WE NOW KNOW THAT
THE FBI SHARED INTEL WITH THE
CAPITOL POLICE REVEALING THAT
SOME JANUARY 6TH ATTENDEES WERE
PLOTTING AND ATTEMPT TO
VIOLENTLY STORM THE CAPITOL.
THAT IS THE DAY BEFORE, "AN
ONLINE THREAT DISCUSSED SPECIFIC
CALLS FOR VIOLENCE TO INCLUDE
STATING TO BE READY TO FIGHT,
CONGRESS NEEDS TO HEAR GLASS
BREAKING, THE DOORS BEING KICKED
IN FROM THE INTERCEPTED INTEL,
GOES ON TO SAY, "GET VIOLENT,
STOP CALLING THIS A MARCH OR
RALLY OR PROTEST, GO THERE READY
FOR WAR."
THEY KNEW THIS ON THE FIFTH.
ACCORDING TO THIS DOCUMENT ON
YOUR SCREEN, THE CAPITOL POLICE
EMAILED THE SENATE
SERGEANT-AT-ARMS, WARNING THIS
GROUP THAT IS "PROMOTING THE
PHOTOS OF THE CAPITOL TUNNEL
SYSTEM ONLINE AND STATING THEIR
GOAL OF BLOCKING THEM FROM EVEN
ENTERING THE CAPITOL.
THE SAME REVEALED RIOTERS ARE
PLANNING TO CREATE A PERIMETER
AROUND THE CAPITOL.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT INTELLIGENCE
ON JANUARY 5TH, D.C.
MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER WROTE A
LETTER THAT DAY TO THE DOD
EXPLICITLY ASKING THEM NOT TO
DEPLOY NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TO
THE CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6TH.
WHY WOULD SHE EVER MAKE THAT
DECISION?
AGAIN, WHY DIDN'T THEY LIFT A
FINGER, WITH ALL THE
INTELLIGENCE THEY HAD AHEAD OF
TIME, TO PROTECT THE CAPITOL, TO
PROTECT EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL.
IS ANYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE, ARE
THEY EVER GOING TO ASK THAT
QUESTION OF MAYOR BOWSER?
ARE THE EVER GOING TO BRING IN
NANCY PELOSI AND ASK HER WHY SHE
DIDN'T CALL AT THE GUARD?
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
APPARENTLY, BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE NOT BEEN INTERVIEWED.
ACCORDING TO ALL OF THE REPORTS
I AM READING, THEY ONLY SEEM TO
CARE ABOUT ONE THING, AND THIS
IS SAD, BECAUSE THAT HOUSE IS
OUR HOUSE.
THAT IS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE.
THAT IS YOUR HOUSE.
AND WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
INSTITUTIONS BE IT I DON'T CARE
IF YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT.
I SAID IT ON THE 6TH.
WE'VE GOT TO PROTECT OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
AND IT SEEMS THEY ONLY CARE
ABOUT SMEARING TRUMP, EXCITING
THEIR BASE, MAY BE RAISING MONEY
OFF ALL THIS.
WHICH NOW BRINGS US TO
JANUARY 6TH.
NOW, THAT MORNING, DURING HIS
SPEECH, PRESIDENT TRUMP --
REMEMBER, HE SAID THESE WORDS
AND THEY HAVE YET TO BRING THEM
UP, WHAT A SHOCK -- HE SAID MANY
OF YOU NOW WILL PEACEFULLY AND
PATRIOTICALLY MARCH TO THE
CAPITAL SO YOUR VOICES MAY BE
HEARD.
DIDN'T CALL FOR VIOLENCE, KIND
OF JUST THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID ON THE STEPS
OF THE U.S. SUPREME COURT WHEN
HE THREATENED JUSTICES, AND WE
ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
ANYWAY, HERE IS THE PRESIDENT ON
JANUARY 6TH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I KNOW THAT EVERYONE HERE
WILL SOON BE MARCHING OVER TO
THE CAPITOL BUILDING TO
PEACEFULLY AND PATRIOTICALLY
MAKE YOUR VOICES HEARD.
>> Sean: OKAY, UNFORTUNATELY,
WHEN THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE
FEATURES THEIR CLIPS FROM TRUMP,
I'LL BET ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY
THEY'RE GOING TO SLICE AND DICE
AND EDIT AROUND THAT PART WHERE
HE SAYS MANY OF YOU WILL NOW
PEACEFULLY AND PATRIOTICALLY
MARCH TO THE CAPITOL SO YOUR
VOICES WILL BE HEARD.
I WONDER WHY.
NOW, IN THE HOURS THAT FOLLOWED,
CAPITOL POLICE, THEY WERE
ILL-PREPARED, THEY WERE
OUTMANNED, AND ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENTS AFTER ACTION REPORT,
ANTIRIOT SQUADS DID NOT RESPOND
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
MANY OF THEIR RADIOS WERE NOT
WORKING.
AND MUCH OF THEIR RIOT GEAR WAS
LOCKED IN A BUS AND THEY
COULDN'T FIND THE KEY.
NOW ULTIMATELY, THE
CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF REQUESTED
THE NATIONAL GUARD AND ASK FOR
HELP SIX DIFFERENT TIMES, AND IT
WASN'T UNTIL WAY LATE IN THE
AFTERNOON THAT PELOSI FINALLY
SAID OKAY.
BY THAT POINT, IT WAS TOO LATE.
THE CAPITOL HAD BEEN BREACHED,
AND EVER SINCE, DEMOCRATS HAVE
USED THIS AWFUL DAY AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
RIOTS OR IMPROVING SAFETY AND
SECURITY.
IT IS ALL POLITICAL.
REMEMBER, RIGHT NOW, THERE IS NO
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE.
ASK YOURSELF, WHY DON'T WE HAVE
A COMMITTEE LOOKING INTO THE 574
RIOTS THAT TOOK PLACE IN THE
SUMMER OF 2020.
DOZENS OF DEAD AMERICANS.
THOUSANDS OF INJURED POLICE
OFFICERS.
BILLIONS IN PROPERTY DAMAGE.
WHERE IS THAT CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE ON THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE IN PORTLAND,
REMEMBER, NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, LIT
ON FIRE FOR WEEK AFTER WEEK, BY
FAR LEFT PROTESTERS.
WHAT, NO HEARINGS ON THAT?
THOSE LIES DON'T MATTER?
THAT PROPERTY DAMAGE DOES NOT
MATTER, THOSE POLICE DON'T
MATTER?
HERE W